I have you have already 150 from 4000
views only a lot of open applications
everybody's a [ __ ] creator
hundred and thirty
what I was I was trying to finish there
everyone's a Kratos wins a slain for
your like it like to make the joke that
even you're a creator even though you're
not yeah you in your own zone see on my
way to a talk to chase my client
vaynermedia's client looking forward to
that 28th morning Wednesday hope you
guys are all doing super well trying to
figure out our cadence with the new edit
style reading all your feedback today is
not a bunch of sleep so kind of it will
get it going in a minute here the game
fires me up you know for me the
mentoring of Tyler is super important
he's my assistant my lead assistant we
have two now with Z seen her running
around and I think a lot of you who are
running businesses don't realize that
the conversations and the mentorship on
a day to day basis teaching them the
long game the short game what your wants
and needs are what you see in them how
they can be better is a huge
vulnerability you guys just want
everybody to click right into your
expectations without you putting in the
work a lot of you have bad puppies and
dogs because you didn't spend the time
up front to put them in the right
position a lot of you have kids that
aren't reaching their expectations of
you because you took for granted there
was early five or six years I mean if
you want somebody to be successful in a
long term you have to disproportionally
put up work in the front to make them
successful and that's what I'm doing
with Tyler and ironically that's what I
was teaching him to do when somebody new
joins the team and that's something I've
taught you d-roc that's you know
something that you've struggled with we
all struggle with that like you know
when you add somebody new your thought
is this is gonna be easier now I can do
more I can do better I can do faster the
problem is for the first 60 90 100 days
you get slower because you have to put
it all into them you have to answer all
those questions you have to fix all
their you know misses and so and then
what if they don't even work out what if
after 120 days it's not the right person
you oftentimes don't make the move that
you have to and bring in somebody new
and then you have a year of them two or
three years or some of you are sitting
on four and five and six years of
somebody who's not good
to do the thing you want these are very
difficult tasks of a CEO you see me and
meet Gary what do you do meetings I must
travel around in a IC o----
also next we have creative friends
Vayner through Gary this our position
has creative friends all over the world
and we would like to use them to create
some content that is more you know what
I would call obtainable luxury let's
start using that hello everyone its
craft brew Alliance that's cool
see you nice guy he's great Andy what it
was craft brew line here gonna beer so
they took a bunch of small breweries and
you introduced me to them yeah I am on a
mission to turn my family's liquor store
into the leading craft beer retailer in
America and I want to start rounding up
all the those relationships on this
episode the wonderful side Wakeman is
here bye you're on dailyvee now ok
officially awesome give me three words
everybody should be thinking about oh my
gosh where the three stop believing
everything you think that work yes okay
yeah love you thank you another chef
stop believing is one stop believing in
everything you think seven when I got
asked three words I nailed it you're
gonna die building an agency or you want
to build a media platform there's a
place to play and I'm trying to figure
out where you guys want to go are you
still debating it I'm asking here yeah I
respect that yeah I'm debating 900
create our own
our brains of the companies that we work
with but we also recognize that there's
a huge social component that we're still
trying to build out as well but the
clients that we bring in
but this platform at this side of the I
guess house house right is solely
focused on creating content whether that
it's brain work or creating original
stories or compelling so is it right
cool so you guys know each other you
said it does okay
and so what the thing that the thing
that you're thinking about now is you
want to produce original content around
you how should I be thinking about
what's my perspective I'm sure you guys
have your perspective and what's the
best the thing that you guys think that
maybe I know even better than your own
subjectiveness is the distribution of
okay right well the conduit to the story
is here 100% and if I could share a
story for some for a player and let
folks know what's inside the helmet
using him as the conduit that's
information that yeah I mean if your
story do you said it's information I
think you know this they have versions
of them getting that I think the bigger
part is if you're a good storyteller
you always have options I'll wait for
that video love you talk to you soon
yeah I really came here to New York just
to meet you really it's funny I was just
sitting in there waiting and I got the
notification on my phone from YouTube
from your channel saying you were
looking for content creators and I'm
like hey I'm a content creator let me
get right to the punchline I've figured
out that what I'm offering is incredibly
interesting and game-changing and that I
believe that there are tens of thousands
of people that can either afford to or
believe that it's the right strategic
decision for them to come and work on
this team for $15 an hours for two years
and I don't take lightly New York City's
expensive I believe in my thesis I
believe
that you should live with for people if
you want let me I believe in I'm just
offering things you're more like I also
know that some people have rich parents
but we're about to hire a lot of people
who can do pre and post film and post
content for social and and I'm gonna
hire a lot of them so to be very blunt
if you're yes to the first part well
then you'd better send them to some
content ASAP then give them some sense
and by the way we're not looking for
slow we're not looking for fire we're
looking for nuances that make us believe
that we can get them to fire
it's the work ethic that we're looking
for we want somebody who's excited about
making snapchat content for 15 hours
somebody who's excited about taking that
interview that you just watched and
chopping it up you know we do not hear
you know where I can just leverage the
brand association for them my man I have
no idea why you're standing in my office
right now but your time
it's truly I don't know I don't know why
you're here I can tell you that timing
is really [ __ ] good because if you
literally came here three months ago I'd
be like yeah definitely like send an
email like we're not thinking about it
the way we did five minutes ago now I'm
thinking it as I'm gonna find 15 of them
ASAP because I'm gonna teach them here
and then they're gonna be the foundation
of the next version of vaynermedia but
if you're interested you need to set as
long as I mean at some level I don't
know what they're a barometer of like
giving you a yes and giving Susan's
watching now cuz I'm going to put this
whole video out cuz this explains what
I'm up to more than anything uh yes but
uh you should do that immediately
because I'm gonna put out this video of
you and I right now in addition to the
form pretty soon like I don't know
tomorrow so I highly recommend you do
quickly and so look I can literally talk
an entire book out in one breath but I
can't write two sentences together
coherently so in January when crushing
it comes out it will be my fifth New
York Times bestselling book I find that
laughable for a man who can't write
three sentences together it's because I
created infrastructure in step
Neal and my ghostwriter and I am betting
on my strengths of video and talking
gift of gab I'm the number one followed
person on medium I can't write I have
Colin Campbell who's a beast in
transcribing me he listens to you listen
I'm filming this right now don't pitch
me hey let's do betting on your
strengths
he'll transcribe everything here but
I'll be missing some stuff he'll call me
and interview me I think I think I think
people are I think people grew up in an
environment or had its nature nurture
you are scared and you have allowed
failure to be on the offense and I don't
want to spend any time in this article
on whether you were born with it or you
were conditioned to be that way based on
the way your parents parented you or the
environment you were in I just want you
to recognize that truth and start the
process of putting all your time and
energy and figuring out how to go
backwards on that good content day I've
what up it's finally official I had a
triple confirm it so I wasn't promoting
it October 9th
Columbus Day Monday in New Jersey at the
West Orange Manor we have the Wine
Library charity event where we donate
all the proceeds to I think the Crohn's
and Colitis foundation and obviously
with AJ and I'm doing something super
cool which is a high-end wine tasting
and QA just wanted to make a quick video
about the $500 ticket in the sea now
that you saw business and wine Q&A
session this event is going to be part
of the super tasting that you see super
tasting something we started 2001 right
16 years ago if you were in the
tri-state area
or if you've ever wanted to come and
really chop it up with me this is the
plane ticket either by Columbus Day
Monday New Jersey is a limited 40 or so
tickets for this 500 dollar business and
wine high-end tasting of I love you back
Seth Seth are Seth that's you Seth
they're supposed to be [ __ ] Seth dude
you need to be you need to be working
here no wonder my podcast is slipping
down the ranks Seth is like on it's the
rim wha except what you have to say for
yourself here
are you excited about the super tasting
are you gonna go good so much right
super dazing check it see ya hey awesome
hi how are you nice to meet you is to
meet you how are things very very good
oh you know the whole 60 second you know
the whole 60-second Club thing the rules
of 60-second Club is all the next year
on Instagram I'm gonna reward my
hardcore community for everybody who
likes an Instagram post and leaves a
comment in the first minute of an
Instagram post so that's why I got to
turn on notifications so you see it
comes in a bunch of you are in which I
continue to recommend you do well I give
t-shirts and books out but sometimes I
give the ultimate prize which is access
to me so this was a 30 minute win right
yes what are you from I'm from Florida
if I live in Atlanta you know what you
need to do right you need to try as many
things as [ __ ] possible but I mean
for real like you need to go and hula
dance you need to go try to take pizza
making classes you need to travel with
scrap up money and like you everybody
can do everything with very little money
everybody thinks you need money barter
Tyler has skills and making videos right
yeah he could literally do anything he
wants in the world you want to do
something barter barter is a real trick
if you got some like how do you think
[ __ ] went down before money yes sir like
you have meat cuz you have a cow and I
have [ __ ] fruit cuz I have a tree you
have you have clothes cuz you can
[ __ ] sell and I've got [ __ ] paint
cuz I figured out how to make it like I
don't know like barter I would type in
your location on Instagram every night
put into town actually let's do it
together butter photo right now put it
in places put it into places and
literally business develop my way into
new experiences like who's this person
took these caterpillar pictures he's a
visual art and paint maker
he took these incredible like right you
see it yes should just EMM yeah like
first of all you have to think that is
Rattus I do and be like hey man that's
super rad
he's like next thing you know he's
teaching you how to [ __ ] paint
caterpillars yeah like that's life yes
just open up your world somebody is
going to watch this video or listen to
this podcast email me in 21 years and be
like I became a world world famous jelly
maker because I watched you interview
some girl like who was a college student
you told me the DM move I [ __ ] did it
cuz I was like [ __ ] it i DM this person
he taught me how to make jelly and it
end up being the thing that I was best
at in the world
reach it out you're gonna film here
please meeting yeah all right guys I'm
trying to drink these shakes like
anyway good day a lot of content got a
HR meeting now some leaders got a couple
more senior media internal meetings so
three or four internal meetings now get
home off to Seattle tomorrow see ya
you feel like we should do something
cool here we're pure Wow starts invade
like there's you know like isn't that
place where you can stand in four states
in one spot